yeah i mean when we looked at you know
the defense
uh in after the season evaluated you
know it was
it was pretty barren in there and so we
had to address that and
you know honestly at the end of the
season i was kind of down in the dumps
when i kept looking at the
depth chart and knowing what kind of
salary cap space we had
and so you know like i said rob's done
and up and rick
have done an unbelievable job doing that
and
they've got me regenerate rejuvenated
uh with the guys that they've brought in
and the players that they've been to
help and then they've got guys like
anthony barr who
who you know he decides to restructure
his con
contract because he wants to be here you
got guys that
like stephen weatherly and mckenzie and
you know a lot of these other guys that
that really want to be here and patrick
peterson and so
you know those those kind of things get
me excited
mike zimmer vikings head coach
rejuvenated by the things they've done
on the defensive side of the ball i i
don't
know that it will matter much if the
left side of the offensive line is
constantly caved in on kirk cousins
because riley reef was cut they better
have a plan
at left tackle but we're going to do a
draft on this thursday edition of pftpm
of coaches who should feel rejuvenated
based upon what's happened so far
in free agency miles because i'm in a
semi-good mood in the full
effects of the second coven vaccine have
yet to
reach me i'll give you the first pick
well it was a good mood
boy you know the first segment of the
show and i guess over the last 35 36
minutes
being around me has just brought that
down but i love the first pick because
i'm gonna take bill belichick because i
think that if anybody should feel
rejuvenated it should be him look bill
belichick
has not done this in free agency we saw
robert kraft say this to peter king
that you know usually all the teams that
spend a lot of money in free agency
the patriots sit back and they start
laughing but this year
they didn't you look at what they've
done and they got the graphic up right
there look matthew
judon another guy that you know it's got
35 34 and a half career sex
somebody that can be productive i think
all the things that they've also done
offensively when you talk about getting
two real productive tight ends and joe
new smith and hunter henry
you sign somebody else like nelson agle
or kendrick bourne all those guys
it's really lining up at least for them
at this point to be much better than
they were at seven and nine
um right there in the 2020 season now
this year they could you know get above
that 500 mark maybe
it just ends up that they are nine and
eight but they could also be ten and
seven
perhaps even 11 and six i don't know but
i just feel like
at this point with the moves that
they've made in free agency so far in
this offseason so far
bill belichick should definitely feel
rejuvenated and and it's
it's weird to think that because
basically he's cleaning up his own
mess it's his own fault that he needed
to get rejuvenated because they've done
such a poor job drafting in recent years
as his boss robert kraft said yesterday
and
they're hoping to have a better draft
and they clearly have made an impact in
free agency i'm going to go sean mcvay
the rams coach he's made plenty of
messes in la
giving out contracts he shouldn't have
given out to guys like todd gurley and
jared goff they dumped goff
tucked him into that matthew stafford
trade so it wasn't obviously
a brock osweiler hot potato move which
it was
they get matthew stafford they add
desean jackson for the two games he's
healthy enough to play he should make a
real difference
but i'm just i'm kidding if he can stay
healthy he will make up
a huge difference with a downfield
threat and even if he doesn't play a
game
even if he doesn't play a game matthew
stafford makes the rams better they've
still got an awesome defense
and in the toughest division in football
given the extent to which
jared goff had to have driven sean mcvay
crazy the past couple of years
mcveigh's got to be feeling a lot better
about the quarterback that he has you
know i've heard people say that
that stafford is a level above goff he's
more than a level above golf in my mind
oh you mean michael brockers who now had
to apologize for that
uh because he and jared goffer are
teammates again yeah
i agree with you i think sean mcveigh
should definitely feel rejuvenated and
he's probably somewhere
in southern california in the lab
cooking up plays that will also
beat zone coverages because they'll be
able to do that now i think
the next person is still in california
but because he can get his quarterback
of the future
i think it's gotta be kyle shanahan he's
gotta be feeling
very rejuvenated probably because they
have now traded up
to number three overall they're going to
be able to get somebody who they really
believe in as
a passer and i think the nice thing has
been that
they're not really shy about the fact
that
what they have done is to go up to trade
for a qb and i think
whenever you're in year four year five
as kyle shanahan
is getting into now and you don't have
that solid franchise quarterback you
know you need to get one
and clearly they have evaluated it that
jimmy garoppolo is not that guy
and i think mike you and i both agree
that by week one jimmy garoppolo will
probably be elsewhere so he could be
somebody else's quarterback of the
future
but the san francisco 49ers quarterback
of the future is probably going to come
from this number three overall pick you
know cleveland's not that far away
i i i i i when you least expect it
expect it
miles i'll go with jello mike
i'll go with the low hanging fruit here
of mike zimmer uh because he's a
defensive guy he's an old school
defensive guy
and his secondary specifically his
corners were so bad
last year and they tied up all that
money in anthony harris as a franchise
player
at safety after they had groomed him
from undrafted into a guy that they
thought
enough of to apply the franchise tag and
last year he just wasn't very good
those new bodies in the back end of the
defense
will will make him happy now he still
needs a pass rush
and he's got to get this all figured out
with danielle hunter and he seems to
think
that it is but uh to the extent that the
pass
rush will struggle they'll have better
options
behind the pass rush to try to keep
receivers from running free which we saw
all too often also
the notion that there probably will be
fans this year
at u.s bank stadium even if it's not
full some fans
better than zero fans which makes it
hard for the vikings to have a home
field advantage
no doubt that is one of the best uh game
day environments that there is
in the nfl the school chant right before
kickoff is one of the most fun things
and also when they score touchdowns and
it sounds like their explosions going
off before they blast prince's let's go
crazy that scares me every time i'm in
the press box but it's also very fun
um all right next person uh since we
were told that we could choose
coordinators you know you chose sean
mcveigh i'll go with somebody else from
the rams
and that's where he morris and i think
he should feel pretty rejuvenated
because
last year he started out as the atlanta
falcons defensive coordinator then got
elevated to interim head coach
once dan quinn got fired that could be
tough on anybody but i think it also
would rejuvenate anybody
when you then go over to the los angeles
rams and become the defensive
coordinator of what was
the number one defense in football last
year in both points allowed
and yards allowed and you get to coach
aaron donald
and jalen ramsey they just signed
leonard floyd two to a long-term deal so
if anybody is a coordinator and should
feel rejuvenated i would believe
it should be rahim or she has a chance
to take over a great defense
i've got a coordinator too and i would
have
gone with this one earlier but once you
went with belichick i knew you wouldn't
take this
next guy this is my final pick the final
pick of the draft i'm going josh
mcdaniels i think mcdaniels
has even more reason to feel rejuvenated
than belichick because
mcdaniels didn't make the mess mcdaniels
didn't run off tom brady
mcdaniels didn't draft all those crappy
skill position players all due respect
to the individuals who were selected
mcdaniels is just trying to make chicken
salad out of the chicken
crap that belichick and nick casario had
given him in recent years and i'm sure
at some point he thought i didn't go to
indianapolis for this
now he's got a chance to become an
offensive genius again i mean isn't it
amazing
miles the way that the nfl hiring cycle
works
that if you're the coordinator of a
great offense
on a winning team you're one hell of a
coach but the minute that that team has
bad players
and isn't winning you forgot how to
coach and
and i know that that leaving the colts
at the altar is something that mcdaniels
is having a hard time living down and
it's keeping teams from pursuing him but
i guarantee you
that if the patriots of 2021 have an
offense like the patriots of 2007
mcdaniels is going to be at the top of
the a list when it's time to look for
coaches next year so
he's definitely rejuvenated in more ways
than one because
now he may have a chance to get real
consideration
to be a head coach i mean he lost a he
lost a face-off
this year with nick ciriani in philly
and last year with kevin stefanski in
cleveland two guys
who who have far less experience and
success than him
well i think look for the browns we can
say that it certainly worked out for
them
jury is certainly still out on nick
ciriani but i think you make a good
point with josh mcdaniels it's just
that who is their quarterback of the
present let alone the future right i
feel like
if we have somebody in cam newton that
you know we know
has some struggles throwing the football
then i don't necessarily know that he's
going to be able to be that guy that
gets them through
all 16 games we've both mentioned jimmy
garoppolo being a quarterback of the
future candidate for the new england
patriots
i just feel like that's something that
could happen
whether or not it jimmy garoppolo gets
traded from san francisco or
he just eventually gets released before
week one but yeah they've got to figure
out who that quarterback of the future
is going to be i'm sorry i can't even
just will you please stop it and you
know you mentioned jimmy garoppolo if i
was a patriots fan
i assume you're being egged on by matt
casey if i was a patriots fan i would
not want anything to do with jimmy
garoppolo i'm sorry
the guys made plenty of money do not
feel badly
for jimmy garoppolo he's had his chance
and it hasn't worked because the guy
can't stay healthy
i am not casting my lot i am not risking
my future i am not pinning my hopes
to a guy who can't stay healthy at the
one position other than punter and
kicker
that is protected more than any other by
the rules
against against contact and as sim says
all the time garoppolo doesn't have the
the he's not sufficiently you know he's
in great shape but he's not sufficiently
fleet of foot to get out of harm's way
and he doesn't make the best decisions
he he injured himself
trying to be tough guy on the sideline
and dropping the shoulder into the chief
defensive back and tearing his acl i
don't want anything to do with jimmy
garoppolo
if if i'm a fan base and he's an option
to be a starting quarterback because
he's going to play and he's going to
look good and he's going to get hurt and
you're going to be
you know stuck with nick mullens or cj
beathard all due respect to that
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports